[Music]
battlefield one fans have been patiently
waiting for the shooters first DLC
expansion and it sounds like they'll get
a look at it soon enough I'm Matt and
this gamespot news update has your back
on the battlefield developer dice is set
to announce new details about
battlefield ones first expansion they
shall not pass next week the developer
released a teaser which shows a club
wielding soldier emerging from a blaze
and standing in front of a French flag
we know that the expansion is set during
the Battle of Verdun in France and will
feature maps based on the semi new
village and for de veau in addition to
maps they shall not pass will add more
weapons and dog tags no release date has
been announced but people who own the
fifty-dollar premium pass can play all
of battlefield ones expansions two weeks
before everyone else more details about
they shall not pass will be announced
next week so we'll report back with more
information as we receive it until then
you can get all of your news about
battlefield and the world of video games
right here at gamespot
you